oh
[Applause]
there he is what's up noah
michael jackson
you're ready
[Applause]
[Music]
lil wayne y'all
the carter
yeah yeah yeah
i'm coming to y'all straight from rikers
penitentiary [ __ ]
you heard me
haters out there think i'm playing i
think i'm some kind of joke man yeah
young man that hell yeah check this out
right here man
i'm a badass [ __ ] on this whole
prison here [ __ ] yeah you heard check
it out let's go i'm the baddest dude
[Music]
that's right yeah yeah yeah cause i'm
coming for y'all you know what's up man
i run this yeah in fact yo let's go i'm
the baddest where you going man where
you going hey man where you going you
ain't got to go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
right here
[Music]
i don't think we should be doing this
[Music]
[Music]
yo
[Music]
this is whittaker i have been
babysitting for 20 years i've seen it
all the thing is uh
forrest is a unique child everything is
gonna be fine i want you to have a good
time tonight you deserve it
okay um
good luck
thank you
[Music]
hey there forrest
gugu guy guy
i want
i want milk
you want me to get your your bottle
buddy i want milk okay
[Music]
this is a baba
i want mama's milk
why can't i have mama's milk
it's a simple request
what yeah well uh you you can't have
mama's milk right now buddy um how about
we play okay
i want
i want i want to play with my legos
okay yeah okay buddy let's uh get your
legos done
i wanna
i wanna put the smallest lego in my
mouth that's all i'm gonna do no no you
can't you can't do that what
first you tell me i can't have mama's
milk
now
became a smallest lego in my mouth
what a night
this is a bad start
rapid force it's dangerous
let me get this straight you're in
charge of me
in my house all right forest it's time
for bed i guess then
you gonna sing me a song
what mama always say me a song before i
go to sleep are you gonna do that for me
okay okay yeah yes i will
hush little baby don't say a
word keep
keep singing mama's gonna buy you a
mockingbird
put my name in it
i like i like it personal
hush baby forest whitaker don't say a
word
mom's gonna buy
you a mockingbird
babysitter and if that mockingbird don't
sing have a good cry
[Laughter]
hey babe
hi
um i made a really big decision without
consulting you
i i went by um
a puppy rescue stand on university
avenue
i had to i had to you got us a dog yeah
i did
so honey i've got to tell you something
okay
these rescue dogs have had some tough
situations and a lot of them take on the
personality of their owners
this dog
was owned by wrapper ice tea
all right little buddy come on
hello my little darling
oh man [ __ ] you
you [ __ ] my
this health thing
okay buddy take it easy
nothing ever been easy for me in my life
hook me up with a treat you want a treat
buddy you want a treat is that what you
want here he goes
um yeah that's a tasty ass treat right
there now give me the whole bag okay one
treat is enough [ __ ] without talking to
you
give me the whole bag of treats cause
i'm a treat killer and a [ __ ]
handful
somebody's grumpy today
grumpy whoopee
lay my ass right up on this comfortable
ass sofa
i'm gonna sleep on this [ __ ] too as a
matter of fact you know what
[ __ ] and [ __ ] i'ma pick them up
here too no oh no no no
raise your hand at me okay um i've got
something for you little guy
huh huh you want to play fetch you want
to play fetch you like fetch get that
ball
you both your condescending
i ain't your entertainment [ __ ] so [ __ ]
you
hello who is this
come on coco don't worry about these
motherf
that's my [ __ ] coco what if i got to
tell y'all she gonna be living here too
wow okay you got your little friend here
yeah yeah well you can uh she could play
here for a while sure puppy playdate
yeah playdate we gonna have a date
that's we gonna have [ __ ] come here
[ __ ]
oh he's frightening are you just doing
that oh no don't do that oh yeah that's
my [ __ ] suit okay oh dear get the [ __ ]
out of here it's about to get graphic in
this [ __ ]
how come you don't do that with me honey
i told you he does it i just want to
keep this area clean
hey
what's up ted and annette come on in
yes all right thanks for coming
have a bloody good time
awesome
oh
there he is what's up noah
michael jackson
um
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go
all right three's the show
four all right well annie are you okay
oh he's leaning he's leaning are you
okay hey are you okay danny are you okay
annie you've been touched by
a smooth criminal very nice oh shamone
more kicks closer more closer close to
your face you're out you're almost
you're really
no where's your mom
you want to come inside
that's annoying that is very annoying
stop stop
don't do it anymore
oh great simone just keep doing the
shimon that's where the children act
where's the cheese
that's some bad taste
this isn't
don't even know what that is thriller
eyes
what are you doing get it on jamming no
you're cut off a chamois oh okay
he doesn't slap his ass like that so i
don't know what okay no no no no no no
no no
no no no he doesn't i've never seen him
hit his ass hey
look
hey
can we just
hey stop stop it stop it stop it
the costume's awful the impression is
stupid and played out everybody and
their mother was michael jackson three
years ago when he died
you died
oh
wait wait wait he died oh noah
oh noah
what
now wait a second don't sad and walk
away
[Music]
happy halloween
[Music]
nobody likes you you girl well you're a
different color than me and that's bad
oh yeah well you dress like a now hold
on a second
whoa
mr t
never make fun of the way a man dresses
way man dresses is his business
remember that whether it's overalls
chains or feather earrings however they
dress it's not to be joked about i pity
the fool that judges another man's
clothing
i'm sorry i judge your clothing it's
okay
[Music]
hey scout there's a man over there who
said he'll give us candy if we get in
his van i don't know if that's a good
idea timmy oh what are you afraid of is
it because you have a stupid name like
scout hey
whoa
mr t again
never make fun of a person's name your
mama gave you that name or you made it
up for business purposes either way it's
personal
i'll pity the fool to make fun of
another man's name mr t is a cool name
it's a cool name mr t
[Music]
hey scout want to do some drugs aren't
drugs bad
i don't know
if you're afraid of drugs
we could drink a bunch of alcohol
yum that sounds good
well guess what your hair is stupid
never make fun of another person's hair
hey mr t a person's hair is the artwork
that they present to the heavens
it's just like i've been saying
[Music]
people care about their hair
[Music]
when
[Music]
r is for the real mean jokes you make
and the hurtful little pot shots that
you take
and for your information it's not even a
haircut it's a rare form of male pattern
baldness
your fools
ah
[Music]
good evening my fellow americans
now before i begin
i just want to say that i know a lot of
people out there seem to think that
i don't get angry
that's just not true
i get angry a lot
it's just the way i express passion is
different from most
so just so there's no more confusion
we've hired luther here to be my anger
translator luther
first off concerning the recent
developments in the middle eastern
region i just want to reiterate our
unflinching support for all people
and their right to a democratic process
hey all y'all dictators out there keep
messing around and see what happens just
see what happens watch also
to the governments of iran and north
korea uh we once again urge you to
discontinue your uranium enrichment
program hey mahmood kim jong i think i
already done told both y'all 86
[ __ ] i'm gonna come over there and do
it for y'all please test me and see what
happens on the domestic front
uh i just want to say to my critics
i hear your voices and i'm aware of your
concerns so maybe if you can chill the
hell out for like a second then maybe i
can focus on some you know
and that goes for everybody uh including
members of the tea party oh don't even
get me started on these muppets right
here i want to assure you that we will
be looking for new compromises with the
gop and the months ahead and you know
these gonna say no before i even suggest
now
i know a lot of folks say that i haven't
done a good job at communicating my
accomplishments to the public because
y'all my don't listen
uh
since being in office we've created
three million new jobs three million new
jobs we ended the war in iraq end of the
war y'all we ended a war remember that
these achievements should serve as a
reminder that i am on your side i am not
a muslim and that my intentions as your
president are coming from the right
place they're coming from hawaii which
is where i'm from which is in the united
states of america y'all okay this is
ridiculous i have a birth certificate i
have a birth certificate i have a hot
diggity mama say my massage birth
certificate your dumb ass crackers okay
luther yep rope it in yeah dial it back
luther damn in conclusion
uh last night i had a conversation with
michelle
nope i did not say that i did not say
that
[Music]
well tonight we gonna party till the
party don't stop and the party don't
stop because it keeps on going non-stop
gonna party all night gonna keep this
party going cause the party won't stop
it's been two straight days and the
party's still going two three four five
six seven days till it's friday again
and the party keeps going party all
night cause it's an all night party
friday night 9 p.m hop into the car call
my friends drinks in the back girls up
front going to a party sending texts
cell phone rings ipad facebook party
time skin tight jeans friday nights
dance dance dance cause tonight we going
out and we ain't coming back cause the
party won't stop and we'll go all night
friday night every night the party's
going down down down down
[Music]
friday night every night the party's
going down down down down
new york city l.a chicago houston philly
san diego phoenix austin fort worth
boston memphis denver portland vegas
tucson fresno akron tampa pittsburgh
plano lincoln loving durham salem
[Music]
party party
[Music]
so tonight we gonna party till the party
don't stop who you gonna call
[Music]
hi i'm ray parker jr writer and
performer of the academy award nominated
hear single ghostbusters from the major
motion picture ghostbusters but that's
just one song i've written so many other
major motion picture theme songs and
submitted them throughout the years
now they're available and together for
one specially priced compilation
songs like you tried to play the game
but it's driving you insane
jumanji
danger in the jungle jumanji
there's lying in my house
come on mr computer
throw me a bone i said lawn mower man
get up off of my lawn
when armageddon
[Music]
it's getting legal y'all these songs
have only been heard by the highest
level of industry decision makers but
now you can feel like a hollywood
executive in your own home
i see your face off
that guy walking around it's a face off
that ain't even your face
passion of the christ
give me that off for this cross
passing on the christ you know my daddy
is the boss to
[Music]
now there's a whole lot of kinky bet
that room is stinky 50 shades of grey
all right white people
who's a slave
i'm not a slave oh
12 years i say
what
there's one thing i know is that
persistence makes perfection
sure hollywood missed out but that
doesn't mean you have to
down in the basement
what's going on
it's uh
[Music]
there's a kid and a nasty down there
[Music]
order now to receive your free copy of
bobby sings the twos theme songs to
sequels that were never made
call my agent
jaden pickett smith my man what up clyde
hey look man i'm gonna be real with you
okay this alien boy script i'm not
feeling it i mean it's hard being will
smith's son i just want to make sure my
next project reflects that i'm a
down-to-earth normal kid am i making any
sense yeah yeah i'm reading you loud
clear i've got a script right here very
real called street ball talk to me okay
so you play tony he's a kid from the
streets lives in the hood in a house
with his mom stop
[Music]
house
oh it's like a
tiny mansion got it go on so his mom and
he uh they live in this house and she
works at a supermarket ah
oh uh a supermarket's like a mansion uh
but it's full of food and anyone can go
there so like where the butlers go
yeah basically so so he uh and wait you
said his mom was doing something at the
supermarket working so
working is kind of like acting on a set
every day in a film that no one's ever
gonna see and it lasts for the rest of
your life oh like a maid
yeah yeah she's like the maid of the
supermarket awesome continue so anyway
tony doesn't make the basketball team
right so he decides to start playing
pick-up games of street ball outside so
he plays basketball on his plane
no on the ground
in his limo
no uh outside is that stuff that goes by
when you're inside the limo oh snap he
plays basketball outside the limo door
yeah yeah yeah yeah so then he gets
really good at basketball and then blah
blah blah blah fast forward at the heart
of the story tony has to choose between
his mom
yeah choose is when you have to make a
decision between two things you want but
you can have only one
but
there's two
yeah but i mean he can't have both
what i say about science fiction clyde
it's a no
okay we'll pass
dad bless you thanks
ladies and gentlemen
darius rucker
[Applause]
don't go out with my friends no more
don't wanna hold your hand no more
[Music]
no no no no
i'm not in hootie in the blowfish
anymore y'all
doing my own thing what do you mean in
hootie because you you are hootie man
come on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no no no everybody right now now stop it
stop it
i'm not hoodie
i'm darius rucker all right
i used to be the front man for a band
called hoodie and the blowfish
all right but i was never hoodie there
was never a hootie just if i may if i
may ask where are the blowfish at right
guys
come on everybody blow fish blood fish
blood fish no no no
there are no people known as the
blowfish y'all okay the whole band was
just called hooty and the blowfish
that's it it was a nonsense name
like hoopa stack or toad the wet
sprocket oh
[Music]
don't go out with my friends no more
don't want to hold your hand no more
oh oh and what oh what happened i i see
i get it now i understand hey we gotta
pick y'all we gotta choose between hooty
or the blowfish so who wants to see
the blowfish
[Applause]
hey
hey that that hurts my feelings y'all
but you said you weren't hootie no i'm
not sir but in the question you just
asked the audience i i was clearly
hootie so you are hootie i'm not though
he is hootie
[Applause]
birdie
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we
and now ladies and gentlemen the man
you've been waiting for mr michael
winslow
go get him winslow
bring the noise bring the noise
another sold out night for the kings of
mouth noise gotta tell you though we
wouldn't have this audience without
winslow lucky for you huh
those police academy fans look at all
the t-shirts
six sequels can you believe it every
sound effect this guy makes is like a
little tiny mona lisa popping out of his
mouth have you ever heard him do
the walking through leaves in the fall
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
uh
wow
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
ting
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
me
peace
[Music]
be
wow
[Music]